the purpose of this video is to just
begin to appreciate how vast and
enormous the universe is and frankly our
brains really can't grasp it what we'll
see in this video is that we can't even
grasp things that are actually super
small compared to the size of the
universe and we actually don't even know
what the entire
size of the universe is but with that
said let's actually just try to
appreciate how small we are so this is
me right over here i am
i am five foot nine inches depending on
whether i'm wearing shoes maybe 5 foot
10 with shoes but for the sake of this
video let's just roughly approximate
around 6 feet or around roughly i'm not
going to go into the details of the math
around 2 meters now if you mult if i
were to lie down 10 times in a row you'd
get about the length of an 18-wheeler
it's about 60 feet long so this is times
10. now if you were to put a 18-wheeler
on kind of if you were to if you were to
make it tall as opposed to long somehow
stand it up and you were to do that 10
times in a row you'll get to the height
of roughly a 60-story skyscraper so once
again if you took me and you piled me up
a hundred times you'll get about a
60-story skyscraper now if you took that
skyscraper and if you were to lie it
down
10 times in a row you'd get something
of the length of the golden gate bridge
and once again i'm not giving you the
exact numbers it's not always going to
be exactly 10 but we're now getting to
about something that's
a little on the order of a mile long so
the golden gate bridge is actually
longer than a mile but if you go within
the twin spans it's roughly about a mile
it's actually a little longer than that
but that gives you a sense of a mile now
if you multiply that by 10 you get to
the size of a large city
and this right here is a satellite
photograph of san francisco this is the
actual golden gate bridge here and when
i copy and pasted this picture i tried
to make it roughly 10 miles by 10 miles
just so you appreciate the scale and
what's interesting here and i and this
picture is interesting because this is
this is the first time we can kind of
relate to cities but when you look at a
city on this scale it's starting to get
larger than what we're used to process
processing on a daily basis this a
bridge we've been on a bridge we know
what a bridge looks like we know that a
bridge is huge but it doesn't feel like
something that we can't comprehend
already a city is something that we
can't kind of comprehend all at once we
can drive across the city we can look at
satellite imagery but this is you know
if i were to show a human on this it
would be unbelievably unbelievably small
you wouldn't you wouldn't actually be
able to see it would be less than a
pixel on this image a house is less than
a pixel on this image but let's keep
multiplying by 10.
if you get multiplied by 10 again you
get to something roughly the size of the
san francisco bay area this whole square
over here is roughly that square right
over there let's multiply it by 10 again
by 10. so this square is about 100 miles
by 100 miles so this one would be about
a thousand miles by thousand miles and
now you're including all of a lot a big
part of the western united states you
have california here you have nevada
here you have arizona and new mexico so
a big chunk of of a big continent we're
already including and frankly this is
beyond the scale that we're used to
operating we've seen maps or maybe we're
a little used to it but if you ever had
to walk across this type of distance it
would take you a while to some degree
the fact that planes go so fast almost
unimaginably fast for us that it's it's
made it feel like things like continents
aren't as big because you can fly across
them in five or six hours but these are
already huge huge huge distances but
once again you take this square that's
about a thousand miles by a thousand
miles and you multiply that by 10 and
you get you get pretty close a little
bit over the diameter of the earth a
little bit over the diameter of the
earth but once again we're on the earth
we kind of relate to the earth if you if
you if you look carefully at the horizon
you might see a little bit of a
curvature especially if you were to get
into the plane so you can you can even
though this is frankly larger than my
brain can really grasp we can kind of
relate to the earth now you multiply the
diameter of earth times 10 and you get
to the diameter of jupiter
and so if you were to sit earth right
next to jupiter obviously they're
nowhere near that close that would
destroy both both of the planets
actually would definitely destroy earth
it would probably just kind of just be
merged into jupiter earth so if you put
earth next to jupiter it would look
something like
it would look something like that right
over there so i would say that jupiter
is definitely oh you went on this kind
of diagram that i'm drawing here is
definitely the first thing that i have i
really i can't comprehend i mean you
know it's it the earth itself is so
vastly huge
jupiter is it's 10 times bigger in
diameter it's much more it's much larger
in terms of mass and volume and all the
rest but just in terms of diameter it is
10 times bigger but let's keep going 10
times jupiter gets us to the sun
this is times 10. so if this is the sun
and if i were to draw jupiter it would
look something like i'll do jupiter in
pink jupiter would be around that big
and then the earth
would be around that big if you were to
put them all next to each other so the
sun once again is huge even though we
see it almost every day it is
unimaginably huge even the earth is kind
of unimaginably huge and the sun is that
much is a hundred times more
unimaginably bigger
now we're going to start getting really
really really wacky you multiply the
diameter of the er of the sun which is
already a hundred times the diameter of
the earth you multiply that times a
hundred and that is the distance from
the earth to the sun so i've done my
i've done this i've drawn the sun here
is a little pixel and i didn't even draw
the earth as a pixel because the pixel
would be way too large it would have to
be a hundredth of a pixel in order to
draw the earth properly so this is a
unbelievable distance that between the
earth and the sun it's a hundred times
the distance of the the sun of of the
diameter of the sun itself so it's
massive massive but once again
these things are relatively close
compared to where we're about to go
because if we want to get to the nearest
star so remember the sun is a hundred
times the diameter of the earth the
distance between the sun and the earth
is a hundred times that or you could say
it's it's ten thousand times the
diameter of the earth so these are
unimaginable distances
but to get to the nearest star which is
4.2 light years away
it's 200 000 times and once again
unimaginable it's 200 000 times the
distance
between the earth and the sun and to
give you a a rough sense of how how far
apart these things are
if you if the sun was roughly the size
of a basketball if the average star was
about the size of a basketball in our
part of the galaxy in a volume the size
of the earth so if you had just like a
big volume the size of the earth
if the stars were the sizes of
basketballs in our part of the galaxy
you would only have a handful of
basketballs per that volume so
unbelievably sparse even though the
galaxy looks like even though when you
look at the galaxy and this is just an
artist's depiction of it it looks like
something that has you know kind of the
spray of stars and it looks reasonably
dense there is actually a huge amount of
space that most the the great great
great great great majority of the volume
in the galaxy is just empty empty space
there there's there's there's no stars
no planets no nothing i mean this this
is a huge jump that i'm talking about
and then if you really want to
realize how large a galaxy itself can be
you take this distance between the sun
or between our solar system and the
nearest star so that's that's 200 000
times the distance between the earth and
the sun and you multiply that distance
by 25 000. so if the if the if the sun
if the sun is right here our nearest
star will be in that same pixel they'll
actually be within i mean you know you'd
have to get a ton of stars within that
one pixel even though they're so far
apart and then this whole thing is a
hundred thousand light years it's 25 000
times the distance
then the distance between the sun and
the near star so we're talking about
unimaginable unfathomable distances just
for a galaxy
and now we're going to get our you know
frankly my brain is already you know
it's already well beyond anything that
it can really process at this point it
almost just becomes abstract you know
thinking it just becomes playing with
numbers and mathematics but to get a
sense of the universe itself
the observable universe so we have to be
clear because we can only observe light
that started leaving from its source
13.7 billion years ago because that's
how old the universe is the observable
universe is about 93 billion light years
across and the reason why it's larger
than 13.7 billion is that the light the
things the points in space that emitted
light 13.7 billion years ago those have
been going away from us so now they're
on the order of 40 billion light years
away but just this isn't about cosmology
this is just about scale and
appreciating how huge the universe is
just in the part of the universe that we
can theoretically observe that we can
theoretically observe
it would have to you have to get and
that we can observe just because we're
getting we're getting uh uh we're
getting electromagnetic radiation from
those parts of the the universe
you would have to multiply this number
so let me make this clear 100 000 light
years that's the diameter of the milky
way so 100 000
light years that's the diameter of the
milky way you would have to multiply not
by a thousand
a thousand would get you to
one hundred
one hundred million light years right
there's a hundred thousand times a
thousand a hundred million you have to
multiply by a thousand again
by a thousand
again to get to 100 billion
light years and the universe for all we
know might be much much much much larger
it might even be infinite who knows but
to get from just the diameter of the of
of the of the milky way to the
observable universe you have to multiply
by a million and already this is an
unfathomable distance so
in the whole scheme of things in the
whole scheme of things not only not only
are
we pretty small and not only are the
things we build pretty small and not
only are uh is our planet ultra small
and not only is our is our sun ultra
small and and our solar system are small
but our galaxy is really nothing
compared to the vastness of the universe